New Jersey state beaches and parks are
open for 4th of July after Governor
Chris Christie and Democratic lawmakers
reached a late night budget deal the
agreement came one day after Christie
was photographed with his family on a
state beach that he had ordered clothes
DeMarco Morgan is at New Jersey's Island
Beach State Park tomorrow good morning
good morning for the first time this
holiday weekend the public will be
allowed inside this state park Governor
Christie has an official summer
residence here but over the weekend
those images of him sunbathing while
this beach was closed caused a lot of
backlash up and down the Jersey Shore
this bill is a long overdue significant
reform that will have a lasting impact
on New Jersey residents Republicans and
Democrats struck a last minute budget
deal Monday night it calls for an
overhaul of New Jersey's largest health
insurer in exchange for more than three
hundred million dollars in Democratic
spending priorities this is the best
budget that we've had in ten years but
even as the budget stalemate came to an
end
Governor Christie continued to face
questions over his decision to spend
time during the long holiday weekend at
Island Beach State Park shame on those
people who wanted to make this as if we
were taking advantage or something
Christie and his family had almost 10
miles of Beach all to themselves as a
result of the partial government
shutdown let's be really clear that's
our residents and we have a right to be
there whenever we want to be there I
thought it was insensitive and tone-deaf
kim Guadagno the Republican lieutenant
governor running to replace Christie
said he was out of touch the people
can't use a public beach then quite
frankly neither should be elected public
officials on Twitter Christie said 119
of New Jersey's 130 miles of coastline
were unaffected by the shutdown he was
on the beach for 45 minutes and back in
Trenton that day
this flame banner carried a blood
message for the governor get the hell
off the beach and a pair of jab at its
warning and 2011 ahead of Hurricane
Irene
I think Christie should be ashamed of
himself especially since he gets to
enjoy his on each Christie whose job
approval rating has sunk to 15 percent
according to one recent polled was
ridiculed online his image was
photoshopped its iconic movie scenes and
used as a reminder of the Bridgegate
scandal this is just another example of
our politicians caring more about
themselves than about us late Monday
Governor Christie said he was saddened
that the budget deal came three days
late the government will reopen tomorrow
and state workers will get a paid
holiday of the governor's request Dana
DeMarco thank you